I don't really consider myself married
to Mary
I just if she wanted to if she wanted to
move on and marry another she wouldn't
get an argument with me
how does that make you feel when you
hear Cody say that he doesn't consider
himself married to you and that if you
were able to find somebody else that
he'd be okay with it how does that make
you feel it just doesn't make sense to
me that he would be so frustrated with
Christine and be like she just made this
decision we didn't consult we didn't
talk she just made the decision and then
he says no I don't consider myself
married to Mary
like he just made the decision I've
never heard him say that to me yeah even
since being in Flagstaff he has led me
to believe that he was trying you know
our first anniversary that we had here
in Flagstaff cheers to A New Beginning
you know as opposed to this last
anniversary he's like I don't even know
why you called me Mary he's like like
we're not married we're not acting as
married and I said to him then if that's
where we are don't you think that we
should address that publicly and he said
no I don't want to address it
I don't want to address it I don't want
that to be out there publicly because I
don't want that judgment
where does that leave you
are you still married to Cody or do you
get to decide well he's already made the
decision you just saw him say that you
just saw him say that would you guys
ever think about reconciliation would
you ever think about exfoliation I would
I definitely would but I don't think
that he's
interested yeah did you know there was a
moment in the past that he actually
spoke to me about where he thought about
reconciling
and do you know the moment I'm talking
about I have no idea
[Music]